next y'all Turner joins us now because
these ladies look like a million bucks
and are worth a million bucks yeah and
then so my buddy and all of them are
break it out they're full-on fall
fashion witted Paltrow was showing
flower power in this Gucci full-length
gown
there were sheer panels at the bottom
and a velvet Lotus like flower adorned
the bodice of the dress the 44 year old
star is fluent in Spanish and shown off
her language skills at the Elle magazine
event in Madrid on the other side of the
world in LA
Katy Perry celebrated her 32nd birthday
in this frilly lacy Rodarte dress at the
CFDA Vogue Fashion fun show the dress
came straight from the designer spring
summer 2017 runway Katy hung out with
Nicole Richie and shared the front row
with Emma Stone fear wore a navy accros
tuxedo jacket for her first public
appearance since announcing she and
Russell Wilson are expecting a baby
turns out she and Katy were born on the
same day one year apart
in a rare appearance to me more donned
oversized aviator glasses with this red
print parens the Schouler tunic the
outfit was originally created as a midi
dress but seems to be shortened it and
combined it with black pants making her
own fashion statement and me always
looks great you can also look for her
back up on the big screen she's wrapped
production on three new movie
I